on en parlait en direct avec nous faut
avec maurice lemoine il est journaliste
spécialiste de l'amérique latine
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france à
peut-être d'abord un nom sur cette
commission interaméricaine des droits
humains chargé donc deux enquêtes sur
les événements de cet hiver 2019 comment
s'assurer que ses conclusions seront
impartiale bah écoutez c'est un pari que
fait le gouvernement d'henri sarcelles
dont je rappelle qu'il est il appartient
aux masques de mouvement vers le
socialisme qui est lui-même est le parti
d'evo morales et qu'en fait il a demandé
l'intervention d'un de la série des
lâches pour examiner quelles sont les
responsables des violences qui ont suivi
ce qu'il faut bien appeler un coup
d'état puisque enfin de chagny d'agnès
qui aujourd'hui est en situation un
petit peu difficile puisqu'elle a
gouverné pendant onze mois
un gouvernement de facto qui était
illégitime et aujourd'hui que la
démocratie au venezuela lui d'avoir il
va devoir rendre des comptes sur les
violences qui ont suivi ce cette période
extrêmement extrêmement extrêmement dur
qui a fait 34 morts et de plus de 800
blessés comment analysez vous justement
sa stratégie liens de jeanine agnès
d'accuser le mas d'être responsables de
ces violences faites c c'était une
stratégie assez assez classique elle va
elle peut difficilement endosser la
responsabilité alors que y compris la
communauté internationale ohr pas ce
qu'on appelle la communauté
internationale avait réagi lorsque par
exemple elle a signé un décret accordant
l'impunité totale forces de police et
l'armée pour réprimer les manifestations
et il a fallu que la communauté
internationale s'inquiète pour qu'elle
retire finalement c'est cette impunité
aux militaires ou policiers mais en fait
rendu en fait elle donnait va le donner
à un libre cours aux forces de police et
l'armée pour faire n'importe quoi il
faut aussi rappeler que la la répression
a été extrêmement brutal vous avez cet
ancien ministre d'evo morales qui ont
été enfermés pendant pendant un an
quasiment un an dans l'ambassade dans la
salle du mexique
vous avez des députés qui ont été
arrêtés ils vous avez des collaborateurs
de l'oms à l'aise qu'on était qu'on
était arrêté et accusé de de cause tout
à fait fantaisiste est donc aujourd'hui
effectivement le
le moment est venu de faire un petit peu
les comptes de ce qui s'est réellement
passé en bolivie depuis octobre 2010
mais elle est dans une situation
indélicate baal est en situation un peu
compliquée parce que 40 sont l'un des
hommes forts de son de son pouvoir le
ministre de l'intérieur a retournera
retour au brio qui a été le jeu des red
l'âme damnée de la répression contre les
partisans du mas lui s'est enfui et
aujourd'hui tranquillement installé aux
états unis alors qu'elle allait rester
sur place et que donc elle va devoir
répondre d'une présidence qui était une
fois des danses illégitime en réalité à
ce qui a été d'ailleurs je le précise je
suis pas parti du principe que par
définition de les voir un coup de tête à
un coup d'état qui l'avait amené au
pouvoir d'un certain nombre d'organismes
indépendants en particulier et mighty de
massachussetts l'université du michigan
on pouvait qu'il n'y avait pas eu de
fraude puisque tout ça est parti d'une
accusation de fraude contre à evo
morales qui avait remporté l'élection
présidentielle au premier tour
justement evo morales et à rentrer en
argentine amia à moi des prêts quel est
son rôle politique aujourd'hui
alors il ya évidemment un grand débat
sur savoir qui gouverne la bolivie le
président qui a été élu en octobre
dernier louis saint céré et le président
a un petit peu la logique qu'on retrouve
partout dans ces cas-là sur lui c'est
lui moi c'est moi
evo morales qui a rentré de son exil en
argentine l'exil forcé en d'argentine
est rentré triomphalement olivier et il
est il a été réélu chef du parti donc le
mouvement vers le socialisme est en fait
le président élu et evo morales l'ancien
président vont se partager pour se
partager les rôles dans le retour des
politiques qui ont été
traditionnellement celle du mas depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir d'evo morales en
2006 maurice lemoine
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste de l'amérique latine marciac